the pack is running and the hunt is on
the question is will the Prime Minister
survive forget about the exit for the
moment dozens of journalists are now
working on the voice and Jennifer
Coolidge story
and hardly a day goes by without a new
angle being published the allegation of
course is the bias and Jennifer were
having an affair when he was mayor of
London and he used his influence to fix
up all sorts of inappropriate things for
his American friend now neither the
Prime Minister or mrs. mother Cooley
have confirmed they had a sexual
relationship but neither has been
willing to deny it either so is it fair
for him to be hassled and chased by a
pack of journalists in this way I like
really pursuing the story in the public
interest while Johnson can hardly
complain he was a journalist and in his
time covering the EU from Brussels he is
known to have filed exaggerated or
completely untrue stories the pack have
now scented his blood and I'm afraid
Prime Minister
you'll just have to put up with it those
who live by the sword die by the sword
[Music]
I'm not sure Greg you should be using
that sort of language blurred and die by
the sword
however and the the use of the word PAC
the journalists were a pack were like a
pack of wolves Gavin it actually it's a
legitimate journalists in inquiry
because Boris Johnson is Mayor of London
was mayor when this particular woman was
given a grant by an organisation that
came under the aegis of him 10,000
pounds now he says it was all done
properly and aboveboard fine did you
declare an interest in a friendship with
this woman no I think you probably
should have she accompanied on three
overseas trade trips why and the then
she then got more money from another
government department now I'm not
suggesting that amount of Culture Media
and Sport K planning because Boris
Johnson had given him money before and
we don't know if you've proved that
grant but we're entitled to ask Greg
it's so important that MPs particular
after the great expenses scandal as seen
when they're spending public money to be
doing in the most scrupulous way and
that she refuses to say where they had
an affair I think we can assume Rachel
the
answer is they did because it would be
much easy to say they didn't and
therefore should he have declared an
interest when she got that money I think
he should have I don't disagree with you
i I think I mean there is a packet let's
not kid ourselves the job when they do
them or mass or a pack and they behave
like a pack you quite regularly however
I don't disagree with you I think it is
idolatry word you are invoking it well
it's just a bunch of people doing great
team of people can look after him yes
that's a great you know I think this
story is actually in in a funny way to
play well of him because the real story
behind this is whether he
misappropriated the funds what the media
are concentrating on is whether or not
they had an affair and and I think
Jennifer a career I think that interview
she did on GMB I think she came across
incredibly well I think she came across
as charming and it's lovely
what she did was but where she wasn't
fluffy or or blonde she did this thing
where she she made it absolutely clear
that there was no financial
misappropriation and and and you listen
to her every on everything else she was
kind of you know did and what she did
was it let me just at the end of this
interview I think she came across really
well and I think what she also came
across as as she wasn't then a victim
and she isn't now a victim and I
actually liked her I'd have to get back
to the point note I'm just gonna read
you the mayoral code of conduct quite
clear this is what he was operating on
when he was mayor of the mayor of London
he says holders of public office should
act solely in terms of the public
interest they should not do so in order
to gain financial and other benefit for
themselves their family or their friends
what we still need to know is did Boris
sign off that 10,000 pound grant to her
and she doesn't know anything he does
and he has about that interview was she
left everyone hanging on did they or
didn't they and the media was
concentrating on that let's just have a
quick look at what Boris Johnson said
when he was interviewed by Bethany
beyond sky because so you're not denying
that you wanna live in America a crucial
thing is that in terms of promoting
London
everything was done with complete
propriety and I may say I think it this
is interesting about your private life
its issue about whether you miss use
public money that's why well I know
there was no question of that
but I mean Bose has said that he thinks
that the that this story has been
followed by people who who want to
frustrate brexit and i think i think
that was a mistake for him to say that
and i think it's perfectly legitimate of
rooms either life something but it's not
a striking picture but this is obviously
a hard one for me but I disagree with
what Carol said I don't think the story
is about whether they did or they didn't
and immediately heard what Jennifer or
Korea has said about that and we've
heard what Boris Johnson has said about
that and I don't think that's
interesting or germane to this story
only insofar as it then casts a new
light on why she was in receipt of funds
public money and I think that that is
the only important point that has to be
explored by the press and there is an
ongoing investigation and Danny Street
has provided some submission to City
Hall that I think has been either been
redacted or not being published in the
meantime we do have a labor mayor in
City Hall who has provided the following
statement about the allegations these
are very serious allegations at the
moment they are just allegations I have
asked my chief of staff to ask City Hall
officials to look into what process
there was during this time where these
processes followed but also whether
there are any lessons that need to be
learned Sadiq Khan mayor of London and I
think that's where I'm gonna I just I
don't like I said I don't understand why
the fixation was on the affair and not
the impropriety and the relationship and
conflict of interest but at lunch
oh yeah the alleged conflict of interest
yeah
alleged issue but that's that's kind of
the point and you say you mention the
thing about how he's being conflicted
conflating it with brexit I think we
need to be really really careful
especially those of us who naturally are
predisposed against Boris Johnson the
jump on this only makes him stronger we
should not be building our house on
honest honest on the sand of an
uninvestigated crime find out with facts
carry out the investigation and then
we'll come to a conclusion if there was
a paper trail I think which could to go
right that's when that grant was
approved you think it might have come to
light now because I suspect the mayor of
London has a political interest in all
of this he's labor after all he's very
ambitious this is where a lot of the
informations coming from if there was a
paper trail that directly linked Boris
Johnson to giving that woman a grant I
think he's in serious trouble because he
didn't occur an interest yeah I think I
think you misunderstood what I was
saying I was saying the media should be
concentrating on the misappropriation
but they're not and a lot of the time
they're concentrating on the effect
which is actually doing Boris a favor
because the truth of it is that then
this is no disrespect people would might
have expected for us to have an affair
with someone I think you're doing a
silly comment a disservice I don't think
this is coming from City calm
anywhere near City Hall former City Hall
maybe I mean that's not Livingston city
rule is obliged to investigate yes it is
yeah and it should but all I'm saying is
in that time what the Sunday Times who
have led this year he really will do it
again this week almost certain even if
it's getting a bit thin because that's
what this pack but no one else has
produced any stories around around the
jennifer curry
well itv paid a lot of money kelly
injury but is about 20,000 yeah she was
pitching the newspapers for a lot more
money yeah yes actually I don't say a
lot more than function said so far let
me tell you to be honest we just need
answers and then spinning out and the
media is not going to get anywhere
have an investigation he's saying is
there but if it was a paper trail it
would be there